if you increase their emotional
investment you increase their perceived
value what ends up happening they
actually do get better results when they
sign up for the gym for personal
training versus a 10 a month thing they
get better results and so if you want to
get people the results that you promise
or you claim that you're going to get
them you should stack every single chip
in your favor that's going to get them
the result that you're promising and the
price is one of those things and so some
people want to lower the price because
like I want to help everybody but you're
actually not you're not helping
everybody because most of those people
aren't going to be emotionally invested
they're not going to proceed as valuable
they're not going to get the results
that you so promised which means that
you have to draw a line in the sand and
say I can only help the people who are
swimming towards me